round 7 of the sink filled Cup in st.  Louis the capital of chess in the US  with the finish line in sight the  world's best chess players were intent  on making a move up the leaderboard  five-time world champion Viswanathan  Anand tried to squeeze the life out of  the van uronian but the armenian star  came up with a brilliant defensive idea  to save the game and make a draw former  tournament leader veselin topalov tried  a new idea against anish giri but the  tournament's youngest player neutralized  the entire concept leaving kabbalah  stuck once again in a tie for second  that left wesley so after his draw  against Peter Spindler still sitting  atop the leaderboard with a pack of  hungry wolves giving chase it's a  countdown to the finish line round eight  starts right now